[APPLAUSE]
FRANCIS CHAN: Thank you.
Wow, it is so good to be here.
This is so cool.
I mean, just walking in this
morning and seeing a few of you
guys praying in here,
just praying for-- I just,
I love-- what we do is we have
these house gatherings in San
Francisco, because
I just believe
there's got to be a better way
to do church where we're not
spending a fortune and
making it so professional.
And so we've set up these
house churches with all people.
No one gets paid.
There's zero budget.
All of the money
goes to the poor
or goes to reaching people
on unreached people groups.
And it's an awesome thing.
But it's so fun go to these
different houses in San
Francisco and just see a little
pocket of people worshipping
God with all their hearts,
and go in another house
and it's like, here's
another little circle.
And so to walk in this
morning and see a few of you
just in prayer was like
man, this is so cool,
this worship of God.
And this morning I was
reading, because every day I
spend some time just alone with
God just reading the Bible.
I hope you all do.
Because I'm just,
I'm a skeptic, and I
don't like people just
telling me what's in there.
I want to read it myself.
And as I've been
reading it, I'm like,
no one ever talks about this or
this or this or this or this.
And it's just so good to
go straight to the source.
But this morning I
was reading Psalm 34
where it says, "I will
bless the Lord at all times.
His praise shall
continually be in my mouth.
My soul makes its
boast in the Lord.
Let the humble hear and be glad.
Oh magnify the Lord with me
and that us exalt his name
Together."
I'm just going to bless.
All I want to do
is brag about him
all the time, because that's
what my soul wants to do.
It just wants to brag about
him, not talk about me
and look what I've done,
look what I've done.
It's just about man, it's just
so incredible what he's done
and what he's just kind
of blessed me with.
Even in that situation
you're talking about,
running into this
guy in the middle
of the street a couple years
ago, and I was scared to death.
You know, it's scary.
We've had people
live in our house,
but there was always
people I could beat up.
And it's just like wow
honey, you're on you own.
It's just insane.
But those things that scare
you to death, it happens.
And then to see what's happened
in this guy's life since, now
he runs the whole
ministry in San Francisco.
We opened a restaurant.
He runs a restaurant.
We opened a house for
guys coming out of prison.
He runs all of that.
We just opened a women's home
on Monday, and he runs that.
And he's a pastor now.
And this is after
12 years of prison.
And that's the thing
that God loves to do,
right, is take the
most unlikely candidate
and just do something amazing
so that no one can take credit
for it.
But I just want to
brag about him today
because I feel like that's
what I want my life to be.
My heart is to connect
people with God,
not to connect them with me.
You know how what's his face
gave me an introduction.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's kind of good.
I mean, that's his job.
You just introduce
me and then go.
I don't need to know your name.
Just introduce me.
And that's really
my job right now
is, you don't need to know me.
I just want to introduce
you to someone.
You don't want to
spend time with me.
You want to spend time with him.
That's why I'm telling everyone,
get alone with this book.
You don't need me.
Just get alone with this book.
Look what's in there and
talk to him directly,
because that's what
changes your life.
But this whole idea of how
to get to heaven from Silicon
Valley, the reason why I
make a statement like that
is, some of the
environments we're
in make it difficult for
us to make good decisions.
For example, two months ago--
maybe not even that long,
about two months ago.
Maybe it was longer.
Who cares?
I was at Pebble Beach.
I don't play a lot of
golf, but I enjoy it.
And I was invited
to a fundraiser,
to speak at a fundraiser.
And so I usually say
no to fundraisers.
I just don't like fund
raising for people.
But this was at Pebble Beach.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was for a good cause.
It was Children's Hunger Fund.
So Children's Hunger Fund,
one of their donors sponsored
for a bunch of people
to come to Pebble Beach
to play Pebble Beach and
Spanish Bay golf course.
And then at night I would
speak and talk about the poor.
And so-- whoa.
I don't know this was
up here and unscrewed.
Thank you for being helpful.
Just want to make sure nothing--
AUDIENCE: You're good.
FRANCIS CHAN: --electric,
which happens--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I didn't want
you to have to open it.
FRANCIS CHAN: Yeah,
no, no, thank you.
Thank you what's your face.
OK, so perfect conditions.
Pebble Beach.
Those who golf, you know that's
like bucket list craziness.
Front nine, first
hole, I double bogey,
which is two over what
you're supposed to do,
which is normal for me.
Then the rest of the
front nine, I end up
with a total score of 38.
So I played out
of my-- I've never
played like that in my life.
The caddy even said, I've
never seen anything like this.
He's been caddying
there for years.
He says, "I've seen people shoot
two over on the front nine,
but not at your skill level."
He goes, "This is just
unbelievable," because he
can tell by my swing.
So I just have this amazing day.
And then at night I'm supposed
to talk about the poor
and needs around the world.
And my mind is preoccupied with
India and some things going on.
I was with my buddy Dave.
And we're just talking
through these issues.
And I'm going you know what,
this is like the worst place
to make a decision about how
much money to give to the poor.
There's certain places
where, when I'm in India,
that's when I think clearly.
When I'm in Africa-- my friend
started ministering in Ethiopia
and I've traveled
there with him.
When I'm there in Ethiopia,
I make completely different
decisions than when I make
them in my living room,
or I make them from here.
The whole point is,
my mind gets clouded.
Everything's myopic.
I get focused on the
here and now and this.
Right now, last week, I've
been in a little bit of a funk.
And my wife's like,
what's going on with you?
And I just tell her, my
mind is in Syria right now.
I'm thinking about these
12 million people that
have just lost their
homes-- just like that,
boom, 12 million.
And some friends
of mine-- you know,
I'm trying to get some
people from our church
to go to one of their
bases, because they've
set up these [INAUDIBLE]
for these refugees
in these outlying areas
as they're heading
to Germany, this or that.
And one of my friends who leads
one of the bases in this island
called Lesbos.
You know it's in Greece,
or off the coast of Greece.
And he says, "To give you an
idea of the scope of this,
just our one base, on average,
every day we have people
coming in on these boats.
On average, every day we
get between 8,000 to 10,000
people."
So imagine yourself on an island
and 8,000 to 10,000 people come
every day with nowhere to go.
You're running for your life.
And so they're just
like, we need workers.
We need helpers.
We need funding.
And I'm just like OK, I'm
going to send as many people
as I can.
Let me figure this out with you.
But it's just been in
my mind because I think,
OK, what type of decisions
would you make financially
if you're sitting in
that island and you
see 8,000 to 10,000
people coming off
a boat every single day,
parents with their kids
holding them just frantic,
running for their lives,
and have no idea where to go?
They don't speak the language.
They don't know what
to do-- every day.
OK, so my decision making
there of what I want to do,
what car I'm going
to drive, what
house I'm going to
live in, know where
my kids are going to educated,
just all those decisions
would be completely different
if I'm facing that every day
than if I'm in Mountain View.
And that's the wrestle, right?
I mean years ago, my wife
and I, we sold everything
and we just went to Asia in
the slums of Mumbai in India,
with our kids, just
walking through this place.
We had no home anymore.
And we're just at these
places where our mind's
just open to the world.
And I remember my 10-year-old
at that time was just saying,
"Dad, why are we leaving India?
Look at all the needs here.
How can we go?"
And I'm like, "Well, you
know, I promised some people
in Thailand we'd go there."
And so we went to an
orphanage in Thailand,
lived there for a month.
And he's like, "Well why
are we leaving here?"
I'm like, "Well,
there's people in China.
I said I will go there too."
We're just going
from place to place,
and each time praying
as a family, going God,
is this where we're
supposed to stop?
Because I'll stop here.
I'll stop wherever.
Where do you want
us-- we have no home.
We have nowhere to go.
You know usually you
do that when you're 18,
not when you've got four kids.
But it was just like, God,
I want to stay focused.
And I remember.
I still remember,
I was in Hong Kong,
and I really believed the
Lord just impressed on my mind
that I was supposed to
go back to the States.
And I so did not want to, even
though this was all I knew.
It was like this whole world
had been opened up to me,
and I'm going, I know how
I get when I go back there.
And I remember in the
airport, in Hong Kong,
praying with my wife and
my two oldest daughters.
And we're just scared
to go back to the US,
because we thought we're going
to get stuck in that rut again
and we're going to get
caught up in these things.
And how do we make
sure that when
we go back to America that
we don't just get lame
and just look at our own lives
and just build this for myself
and worry about
retirement-- ooh, what's
going to happen in 30 years
to me-- when there's people
starving today, when there's
moms frantically looking
for clean water
anywhere, and you're
dealing with these issues that
matter for all of eternity.
I remember my wife
just saying, "Look,
we can't let people talk us out
of things this time through."
A lot of times we read
the Bible and we go man,
this is how we
should live our life.
This is the way we're
supposed to do it.
But then nice Christian people
in the US just are saying,
well you don't want to be so
extreme, and think about this,
and think about where
you'll be and how you'll
be 20, 30 years from now.
And it's like, they'll change
our whole way of thinking.
But it was very wise what she
said, just, this time through,
let's not let people
talk us out of things.
When we're convicted,
let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
Let's just make it happen.
And that's what I mean.
In this environment
that we're in,
sometimes we don't realize
what poor decisions we're
making, just based
upon environment even,
just with what we see day to
day and we're not remembering
the rest of the world.
And sometimes we want to
forget the rest of the world,
because it's hard to just go
on with life when you know
that you've got friends on
an island trying to take care
of 10,000 new people every day.
And you've got people
on bases like that.
And then I've got other
friends that-- one just
got out of prison in Iran.
And he's been in
there for five years
and trying to get reunited
with this family and everything
else, and the craziness.
And then what the
Bible says, Hebrews,
"Remember those in prison as
though in prison with them."
So every time I see people
being beheaded or whatever else,
I start thinking,
their families.
How do I remember them as
though I'm in prison with them?
though I'm that little kid
and it's my dad who
just got beheaded,
or my dad who is being tortured?
How do I keep this focus
and still figure this out?
I still have a job to do.
I still have things I've
got to do right here.
And so our minds
can get so clouded.
And that's why
Jesus says in Luke,
there's that story where
this rich young ruler
comes to Jesus.
And he says "Good
teacher, what must
I do to inherit eternal life?"
So this is a wealthy, powerful,
someone who's looked up to.
And he says, hey, what do I
have to do to go to heaven?
And Jesus says, "Why
do you call me good?
No one's good except God alone.
You know the commandments.
Do not commit adultery.
Do not murder.
Do not steal.
Do not bear false witness.
Honor your father and mother."
And he said, "All these things
I have kept from my youth."
When Jesus heard this, he said
to him, "What [INAUDIBLE].
Sell all that you have,
and distribute to the poor.
And you will have
treasure in heaven.
And come follow me."
But when he heard these
things, he became very sad,
for he was extremely rich.
Jesus, seeing that
he had become sad,
said, "How difficult it is
for those who have wealth
to enter the Kingdom of God.
It's easier for a camel to go
through the eye of a needle
than for a rich person to
enter the Kingdom of God."
Jesus gave a whole different
perspective to life.
I had one professor
who said it's
like when Jesus was giving
the Beatitudes on the Sermon
of the Mount, it's
like Jesus went
into the store of happiness, and
he changed all the price tags.
He says no, this is
not what it cost you.
This is not how
you get happiness.
That's not the price you pay.
And the things that we called
blessed-- I mean, I do it too.
Man, that guy's blessed.
She's blessed.
Why do we say that?
Because they're rich,
or they're healthy,
or they've got everything
going their way.
And yet Jesus, looking at this
rich guy, he gets sad for him.
He's like oh, it's so
hard for guys like that.
Earlier he had taught
them, blessed are the poor.
Woe to those who are rich.
Woe to those who
are comfortable now.
And he actually
said it's harder.
It's harder for you.
On Friday, I'm speaking at a
chapel for the Denver Broncos.
I know, it's kind of weird.
But I remember the
first time I was
doing a thing for pro athletes.
I remember just praying.
It was during the
NBA All-Star Game.
And I'm into sports.
I grew up just into sports and
kind of idolizing these guys.
And I just was saying God,
I don't want to go in there
and ask for autographs.
I'm the speaker.
I'm not supposed to care.
But I remember just
praying, going God,
I don't want to go
in here and just
be like-- that doesn't
do them any good.
And so I just started praying.
And God just opened my
eyes, opened my eyes,
helped me to go in with
the right attitude.
And the more I prayed for
them-- man, I'm not a crier.
I definitely wasn't
a crier back then.
But I just started
crying for them.
I started feeling
sorry for them.
I started thinking
man, what would that
be like to just grow up
and everyone worships you
from a young age, because you're
the best kid on the basketball
court when you're eight.
And then you're 12
and now suddenly it's
even in the newspaper, and
then on and on through college.
Then it gets insane.
Now you're in the NBA
now you're an All-Star.
Like this is insane.
Like you're worshipped
all your life.
And now what Jesus calls us
to do is to humble ourselves.
Like he says to this rich young
ruler, man, sell everything
you have.
It's a lot harder
when you have a lot.
And I just got so
sad for these people.
And I started thanking God.
God, thank you.
Thank you that I'm short.
Thank you that not a-- I don't
think I could handle that.
If I'm worshiped
all my life, could I
have ever humbled myself?
And I'm just going
on and on and on.
And just in my prayer
life, like God, I
feel so sorry for these people.
Now I know what you
meant when you looked
at that rich young
ruler and he says,
oh it's like the person Jesus,
you can gain the whole world
and forfeit your soul.
Because there's a moment
that we're all going
to stand before this being.
The Bible describes how
intense of an encounter.
That is every one
that's even gotten
a glimpse, a veiled
glimpse of him,
they either fall on their
faces or they faint.
Or they just go, you're
going to kill me.
I mean, it's just like
this shock of all shocks.
And what the Bible
says the enemy tries
to do here on the Earth is
get is to just not even think
about him.
Get us so preoccupied in
our own little worlds,
you focusing on
this little thing,
assuming that I need a
bunch of Twitter followers
or I want a bunch of Facebook
friends or I want this.
I want this.
I want to build this.
I need to retire like this.
And suddenly boom,
your life just ends.
Now you stand before
this guy and I go oh my.
I was so focused
on other things.
And it just caused me
to go God, thank you.
Thank you for some of
my hardships in life
that made me think through
life at a young age.
My mom died while she
was giving birth to me.
And I'm thankful for that now.
My stepmother died in a car
accident when I was eight.
And I'm thankful for that now.
My dad died of
cancer when I was 12.
And I look back, I go
man, I was 12 years old.
My mom, my stepmom, and
my dad all died suddenly.
And I'm in junior high.
And I'm having to
think about life
and going what, it can
just end like that?
A 12-year-old kid
watching your dad's body
go into a grave, or eight,
nine years old and just staring
at a dead body
realizing it's your mom,
it gets you thinking,
what is this all about?
Is this a joke?
So everything can just
be over right now?
And I started
realizing, God, that
was one of the greatest
blessings in my life,
because it caused me
to start searching.
And while all my other
friends are playing Pac-Man--
I don't even think
Pac-Man was out yet,
Asteroids-- Asteroids
or Space Invaders--
I'm thinking what is the
meaning of all of this.
And you start realizing,
wow, blessed are the poor.
Blessed are those who go
through the difficult times.
He says consider it
pure joy when you're
facing trials everywhere,
because that's
where the character's
built. That's
where the perseverance
is built. That's
where you start thinking
about the things that matter.
But when everything's
laid out for you,
it's very easy to
live a shallow life
and start thinking that
your biggest problem is
what car to buy next, or
what life insurance policy,
or what to investment
in for retirement.
It becomes so huge to you or
how to race to the next thing.
And it's all stuff
where at the end
you go man, what was
I doing down there?
What was I thinking?
Whereas like Jesus says in
Matthew 25, "When I come back,
I'm going to say I was hungry.
You didn't feed me.
I was thirsty, you gave
me nothing to drink.
I was naked.
You didn't clothe me."
And all these people
say, but Jesus, well I
never saw you like that.
And he says, "Whatever you
did for the least of these,
you did for me.
And whatever you didn't
do for the least of these,
you didn't do for me."
And this sent me on
his trajectory of man,
this is what I've got
to do with my life then.
I've got to focus on this.
First John 3, verse
16-- it's funny
how we pick certain verses
and we just gravitate to them,
and we just make the whole
Bible about that one verse.
And everyone knows John 3:16.
And it's like man,
that's a great verse.
I love John 3:16.
But I like the whole Bible.
And I think sometimes we
avoid certain passages.
And it's like John 3:16--
what about first John 3:16?
I love.
"HE says by this we know love,
that he laid down his life
for us.
And we ought to lay down
our lives for the brothers.
But if anyone has
the world's goods
and sees his
brother in need, yet
closes his heart
against him, how
does God's love abide in him?
Little children, let us
not love in word or talk,
but in deed and in truth."
He says this is
how we know love.
Love is don't look at me.
Love is we look at him.
And it says, this
is how we know.
He laid down his life for us.
See what I believe,
and what I believe just
from a simple
reading of scripture
is that there is a being
who recognizes everything
that's going on on this Earth.
Sometimes it
doesn't feel like it
because it says in his
kindness, he lets things go.
He's kind to us in hopes
that we would repent.
And he's patient.
I don't have the
patience of God.
Man, some of the things
I've done in life
at an early age, which I would
hate to have to confess to you,
I just don't know how
a holy God didn't just
strike me down right there.
Like you idiot, how
dare you do that
to this other created
being that I made.
That son of mine or that
daughter of mine, and you
did that to her?
And his patience-- I deserve.
We can all look in this room and
go oh, we're all good people.
But when we go to bed at night
we all know what we've done.
And we know things
that no one else knows.
And then we come back and
oh yeah, I'm a good person,
because we compare ourselves
to someone worse, right?
But ultimately before God,
we know what we've done.
And the Bible teaches
that God saw all of it--
every thought, every
word, every action.
And because of that, I deserve
his punishment, his wrath.
Exodus 34:7 says he doesn't
leave the guilty unpunished.
He's a just god.
He's a fair judge.
We understand judging.
Like a judge, you don't just
let someone go in their crime.
And God says, I don't just
let people go in their crimes.
I'm a just god.
It's justice.
You can't just say OK, you
killed her, but I'll let it go.
No, a just god, a just
judge must punish.
And now his punishments in
scripture seem extreme to us.
But again, we got to go OK,
why do I think they're extreme?
Maybe it's the world I
live in where we're all
about giving rights
where a little kid--
we don't punish kids.
I mean, you see kids.
You ever done child care?
I mean, it's horrifying because
we don't discipline kids
anymore.
They just do whatever they want.
A lot of us grow up in
homes where mom says,
you do that again,
I'll count to three.
Please, don't count.
And so this whole system
of just let it go,
let it go-- we don't get
the justice and punishment.
But that part I always thought
OK, that makes sense to me.
What's fascinating in
the Bible is God says,
let me show you what love is.
This is how you
know what love is.
He says in spite of everything
you've done, I have to be just.
But I also want to forgive you.
And so here's what
I'm going to do.
I'm going to have
my son, my only son,
take the form of a man.
I want to demonstrate--
I want to show the world
love like no one else has.
Just like he's supreme in
his power and his holiness,
his sovereignty, he goes, watch
what I do as far as love goes.
I'm going to have my son pay,
because someone has to pay.
I'm going to have him
pay for your crimes.
No one does this.
Anyone with a child
understands, how in the world
can anyone do this.
And God says that's how
deep my love is for you.
And he says and
he's going to rise
from the dead to show
that he wasn't just
another human being.
And when he rose from the
grave and the people saw,
that's when they said OK,
we'll give our lives for this.
At first we thought it might
have been just a crazy story
about-- but now you just
came back from the dead
and we watched you.
We spoke to you
and we touched you.
And now you're
sitting back in heaven
and you're saying tell
the rest of the world.
So I believe that.
And I believe this book.
And he says, that's how
you learn what love is.
He says that's why-- he goes
when you see someone in need
and you do nothing, he
says how in the world can
you say the love of
Christ abides in you?
He says you're saying that
God's spirit entered into you?
But you look nothing like God.
I mean, we know
what God looks like.
We know about his
love because he
saw a bunch of people
that offended him,
and he went down after them
and he sacrificed for them.
That's love.
And now those of us who
are followers of his,
we follow that pattern.
And so he goes, if someone
calls himself a Christian
yet he sees that need
and does nothing,
you really got to question,
is that person really
a follower of Christ?
He says is the
love of God in him?
How does God's
love abide in him?
"Little children, let us
not love in word or talk,
but in deed and in truth"
And I think that's one of
my biggest frustrations
with what we call
Christianity in America.
It's all about talk.
And that's why I got so
frustrated being a speaker.
And I was known
for being a talker.
It's like wow, he's one of the
best talkers I've ever known.
And yet you look in scripture
and you're just going man,
I don't want to be a talker.
I don't want to
spend my life being
known as a talker or a writer.
I want to be known for my love.
I want to be like Jesus.
We don't look back and say
man, could that guy talk.
We're just like wow, what he
was willing to sacrifice for us,
and love.
And that's why he's saying
look, that's the example.
We ought to lay down our
lives for the brothers.
See that's the picture.
That's the example.
That's why I don't want to ever
boast on hey, look what I did.
Look what I did.
And it's always about man,
it's one thing for me,
a guy who's really
screwed up his life
and was forgiven by God to
experience that, and then
maybe pass it down a
little bit to others.
But it's a completely
other thing
when you've got a holy God
and a perfect son who's
done nothing wrong.
And he says watch
how much we love even
those who've offended us.
That's why Jesus
said, it's no big deal
if you love those
who love you back.
He goes anyone on the
earth can do that.
He goes, but for believers, I
want you to love your enemies.
I want you to pray for them.
I want you to do good
to those who hate you.
I want you to bless
those who curse you.
And again, I do a lot of
work with guys coming out
of prison, guys off the
street, people in other places.
And it's actually
quite enjoyable,
like when you see
their life turn around.
And I don't know if you've
ever been to another country
and to feed someone that
man, wasn't going to eat,
and the look on their
eyes when you hand them
like a bowl of rice or
something and they just light up
and they thank you.
I remember seeing
this one village
and just telling my whole
church, man, I'm like man,
you should have seen
these kids or whatever.
They don't have clothes.
They don't have food.
They don't have schools.
They don't' have
anywhere to live.
And so we built a
school and these homes.
And we're sending all this food.
And I went back to Africa.
And there was a room way
bigger than this, a couple
hundred of these orphans.
And now they're clothed.
And they're in school.
And they're worshipping God.
And I just sneak into
the back of the room
just to take a glance.
And the teacher stops
the class and says,
everyone look in the back.
See that man back
there, Pastor Chan?
Every one of you is sponsored
by someone in his church.
Then all these kids just get up.
Man, you just see
their little heads
and their big bright smile.
And they're screaming
and clapping.
And I'm just like
a puddle of tears.
This is the greatest
moment ever.
Like I got to be a part of this?
I got to be a part of this?
Jesus says, well, that's cool.
He doesn't say that's cool.
He's says that's good.
[LAUGHTER]
But he says you
know what, now can
you do that to
those who hate you,
that won't appreciate
what you've done?
Because that's what I did.
I loved people who
nailed me to a cross.
And I'm going
father forgive them,
they don't know
what they're doing,
even when they persecuted me.
It's easy for me to
maybe go to Syria
and help the victims of ISIS.
It's a little
harder to love ISIS.
It's easy for me to go
overseas and help with Pat,
with human trafficking.
But when it comes to the actual
perpetrators or the ones that
are leading these
rings, and to love them
and to sacrifice for
them, it's difficult.
But that's what God can
give us the ability to do.
And I'm just saying, my life's
been just this crazy miracle
where I just can't believe the
things God's allowed me to do.
And it doesn't make any sense.
But God says look, I choose--
I specifically choose the weak.
I specifically
choose those who are
foolish to shame
the wise, those who
are weak to shame the strong.
This way they don't brag at the
end of their lives and they all
know it's me.
But those of us who think
that we've earned something
by ourselves and we
take credit for it
and we want to brag
about it, man, those
are the ones that God says
gosh, I'll humble you.
I will humble you.
But I'll give grace to
those who are humble.
And I just want to say man,
my story is ridiculous.
It just makes no
sense why God would
pick me and open my
eyes to his beauty,
and then just allow me
to go care for the poor,
care for the needy, and go
around to a place like this
and brag about my god.
And you know, I
think sometimes God
puts me in these
types of environments
or with other rich people.
I know some you guys
think oh, I'm not rich.
No, you're loaded.
You are.
I mean, travel
with me some time.
You are ridiculously
rich and blessed.
And you have people
in the world that when
they hear you work at
Google, it's like ooh,
like this worship thing.
And that's why the first things
I said to those basketball
players or those
football players was man,
I wept for you guys.
I just felt so sorry for you.
And they're like what?
You feel sorry for-- I
mean, it was just the shock.
I go man, I was thanking
God I'm not you.
And they're like what?
And I was explaining to them
because it's so much more
difficult. Like Jesus said
to that rich young ruler,
it's just so hard.
When I'm in the slums of India
and I say hey, give it all up.
There's something better.
They're like,
where do I sign up?
You come to Mountain
View, hey give it all up.
There's something better.
What?
This is Google.
And you go wow, I sure hope they
don't spend their whole lives
gaining the world and
forfeiting their soul,
and losing sight of
the world around them.
Because this is a
very difficult place
from which to make decisions.
But you can make
decisions, good decisions.
I mean, I've never
been to Syria.
I've never been to Lesbos.
I just had someone explain that
picture to me, and I got it.
And it's affecting me.
I'd never even heard of
human trafficking before.
You know, a few years ago,
I was with David Batstone
with Not for Sale, and I'm just
sitting with him at dinner.
And I'm like hey,
what do you do?
And he explains
human trafficking.
I couldn't sleep that night.
I was in a nice
hotel room, but I
couldn't sleep, because
my mind started going,
what if that was Rachel,
my oldest daughter?
What if someone abducted her?
What would I do?
What about Mercy?
And I started thinking
sweet little Mercy,
my second daughter.
What would I do?
I start thinking about my kids.
What if someone took
one of my girls,
I'm getting ready to
speak on a Sunday morning,
and I find out that my kid
is somewhere being repeatedly
raped with no hope in sight.
And I just start imagining this.
And I just couldn't sleep.
I'm just going god,
I would go nuts.
I mean, I wouldn't go
up and go hey everyone,
turn to 1st Peter.
No, I know what [INAUDIBLE]
like throwing this thing over.
I would be swearing
probably, going
what do you guys all sit in
your nice little life doing
your little things.
Someone find my daughter.
You have relationships.
You know people.
Figure this eff-in thing out
because I got to get her back.
You know, this intensity that
I just, I was imagining myself,
what would I do walking onto
a stage if it was my own kid.
And God saying you
know what, I want
you to do that with
all of these kids,
even though they're
not your own.
And I'm just weeping.
Going oh, man, that is--
that's what Jesus did.
That's what I want
my life to be about.
And I'm saying that comes from
a nice hotel room in Atlanta
where everyone's like
oh, Francis Chan's here.
You just say, no, let me
escape that stupid world
and really think about
reality and these people,
because that's a
picture of our God
who says he didn't consider
equality with God something
to be held onto, but
he emptied himself.
He had all the angels screaming
out his glory, and he's just,
I'm going to leave them.
And I'm going to go here,
and I'm going to do this.
And I'm not saying hey,
everyone quit and leave.
I'm just saying you know what?
You surrender your
life completely.
And for some of you maybe
it means to actually go.
But others maybe
you think through.
You know what, how can I use
what I've gotten right here?
My abilities, my income,
how can I use it all?
Can I be more effective
here than overseas?
Because that's
what I realized is
I think I can make a bigger
difference in the world coming
back to America.
And that's why I came back.
I got I don't speak Thai.
I don't speak Hindi.
I don't speak-- I can do this
and I can rally people here.
And I think I do more good here.
And then this book that my
wife and I are writing about,
we were in Ethiopia, which is a
great place to make decisions.
And I'm seeing all of these sex
trafficked women and these sex
slaves in these tiny places with
their kids under their beds,
and man after man
walking in for a dollar.
It's just oh, it's so gross.
I'm like, OK, let's kill.
Let's make this book
the most amazing book.
Let's give every single
dime to these needs.
Come on honey.
And we'll create
an app and we'll
do this and this and this.
And everything will go.
And so we had to recruit
some of you here at Google.
Like man, we're going
to make this app
and we're going to kill it.
We're going to make
it the best ever.
This is going to be the
best app for any book
in the history of books.
And let's get it
out there, and we'll
give it all away for free.
And I'm just going to
ask people, just donate,
and all your money goes to this.
I don't want a dime.
I want to invest.
I want to lose money
on this project
because I want to
be a giver of this.
And so thank God for some of
you that were working hours just
on your own free time,
because you had the gift,
and say OK, I believe
in this cause.
I'm going to go after it.
And it's like you know what,
you're probably better served
doing something like that.
I've talked about
this type of stuff.
A couple of baseball players the
other day were just saying man,
I just got back from Thailand.
I think I'm going
to quit baseball
and I'm just going
to go rescue girls.
I'm like oh, I don't know man.
I mean, I'm sure you're
good at rescuing girls,
but man, you're a good pitcher.
And not everyone makes
$5 million playing catch.
You may want to
consider investing that
and just live in an RV.
Why don't you do that?
Live in a trailer park.
That would make national news.
And maybe that would be an
example to other people.
Like that might be
better for the cause.
So you know, it's just every
person thinking through.
God, I'll go.
I'll go right now.
You want me to go over there?
You want me to go to that little
island he was talking about?
I'll do it.
Or maybe I'll just work
so stinking hard over here
and I'll live a simple,
simple life so that I
can give everything I can.
Sure, I have the right.
Everyone's going to
tell you have the right
to build for yourself.
And Jesus had the right
to stay in heaven.
But his example was love.
I'm not going to hold onto
this I'm going to empty myself
because I love these people.
And that's what we have
the opportunity to do.
But I'm telling you, it's going
to be hard, because you'll
hear this message right here.
And the moment you
walk out this door,
you'll hear a million
other messages.
And they won't sound
much like this one.
And it's like to
remember Christ.
That's why I get alone every
day and go God, remind me
who you are.
Remind me how you live.
And I've got to stop
listening to people.
I've got to block
all that noise out,
because it's difficult to get
to heaven from Silicon Valley.
So those are my thoughts.
I wanted to leave time
for a question-answer.
And what's his face
is coming back.
JON CHUI: OK, well,
what's his face here.
So we wanted to share some
of these practical things
that people could be
doing so that we could
actually action item on them.
Kevin, you want to stand up?
Kev is the CEO of Crazy Love.
And he's organized a lot of the
You and Me Forever app teams
from Google and other campuses.
And so you want to share a bit?
KEVIN KIM: Yeah man.
It's such a blessing to
be here with you guys.
We were praying for
you guys beforehand.
And just our hearts were so
warmed and burdened for you,
and so thankful that
you guys are here.
I actually have a
team in the back.
I've worked with a few of
you on various projects,
and it's been such a joy.
And if you ask them, hopefully
it's been as much of a joy
to them as it was to us.
It's been an incredible
blessing to us.
But we want to extend that
opportunity to you guys.
We do a lot of
great work all over.
And Pat's here.
He's doing amazing work in
Ethiopia as Francis shared.
There's incredible work that
needs to be done in Syria.
We do work in the inner city.
We work with ex-convicts.
And you know, there's
this incredible app
that we're working on right.
I mean, it was Francis's
heart to-- the whole idea was
we had these guys that
are coming out of prisons
and they can't afford
to go to seminary.
And so let's bring
seminary to them.
So the whole idea was
like creating a seminary
in your pocket for free.
And we said we didn't
just wanted for our guys,
but we wanted it for
everybody, like everybody
to have this amazing
exposure to the beauty
and the truth of
scripture for themselves.
And we could have charged.
We could have done
in app purchases.
We could have said,
here's this amazing video
and have it cut off, and $2.99
to watch the rest of it, right?
But we worked
really, really hard.
Francis and I worked really,
really hard to raise the money.
We had to raise
a million dollars
to raise the money so that we
can make it available for free
for anybody, everybody
all over the world.
And we started getting
excited about what God would
do through Read Scripture.
And Jon-- it's not what's
his face-- this is my man.
He's my CTO on the project
for Read Scripture.
So Jon and his team,
they've been working
really hard on this thing.
And I've been praying about it.
And we're so excited
about what God's going
to do with Read Scripture.
But then we started making
these videos in Cantonese.
And we're like oh my
gosh, this is amazing,
and having a heart
for the world.
And we said, wait, I
want to make these videos
in Mandarin and in Spanish
and in Hindi and in Arabic.
We want to roll it out and
we want to do for free.
And so we had this incredible
vision for what God's doing.
And it's a small thing.
What we do is a
small, small thing.
What's been so encouraging is
to travel to all these places
and to realize,
man, God is at work
and he doesn't need any of us.
He doesn't need any of us.
And he is at work
doing amazing things.
And what Francis just
so eloquently shared,
we get to partake in that.
Like we get the joy
and the opportunity
to partake in something
that's cosmic and majestic and
glorious.
And that's a gift to us.
We don't benefit him.
That's a gift to us.
And so for you guys who say
hey, I want to get involved,
and I don't know how.
And I just want to help.
I have a team in the back.
Team, raise your hand.
They'll capture your
information if you want
to help out with our ministry.
But we can also point
you to-- our ministry
is not the only ministry.
We can point you
to other ministries
that we're partnering with.
And so if you just want to
take the step, come talk to us.
And then Jon.
JON CHUI: OK, so Kev, quickly,
there's a door you guys.
So you guys have quick questions
for those who are Googlers.
Let's put some more.
We'll have five, 10
minutes of question.
But Kev, can you share
quickly what you're saying?
A lot of times we just
don't get to see examples.
Like Francis, you talk
about all these people
going to do crazy things.
But we don't see
examples of people
at Google, other than I guess
helping out with this app,
right?
We don't see examples.
So could you share
that story you
shared with us the
other day about the two
developers in your [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN KIM: OK.
All right, real quick, because
we've got to go, right?
But I have a guy.
So we run house churches, right?
And I have a guy that
went to my house church.
Just amazing, amazing guy,
Chris Lee's friend's over there.
Chris Lee worked on my You
and Me Forever app too.
Guy name Greg,
Greg and his friend
Brendan, they graduated
out of Carnegie Mellon, top
of their class, and came
out to work in Silicon
Valley as developers.
And one was at Yahoo.
One was at a medical startup.
And Greg, he goes off on
a mission trip to India.
And his Chinese friend Brendan,
he calls him up in India
and is like hey,
what do you think
about giving up our stuff,
because we have a lot of stuff.
What do you think about
giving up our stuff
and doing something
good with it?
And Greg's like all
right, sure, right?
Comes back to find that
his friend Brendan had
sold everything
that he had owned
and what Brendan had owned,
and gave up their apartment.
He comes home with
luggage and he's
like, where's my apartment?
He's like, there's no apartment.
I took all the money
that we got from selling
your stuff and my stuff.
And we bought this bus.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to live in
this bus, and we're
going to drive
around San Francisco,
and we're going to
house homeless people
and tell them about Jesus.
So that's what these
two developers did
for the better part of a year.
They just went around and had
this incredible adventure.
Now is it pragmatic?
No, right.
But for me, the reason
why it blesses me so much
is because it's a little bit
like that story with Mary
and Martha where Mary breaks
open the bottle of perfume
and pours it out
at Jesus's feet.
And you're like,
that wasn't useful.
That didn't do anything.
That didn't help the poor.
But Jesus was so blessed by
that act of love and worship
and faith.
And when I look at those
two boys and just thinking
about them driving around
in the middle of San
Francisco in their Jesus
mobile bus with this heart,
and you can say, well, how
many people did they house?
How do you measure advocacy?
And you're like, man,
they just loved Jesus.
And they did this
stupid, crazy thing.
And I think that story of
their love and their devotion
still has ripple effects.
It blesses me and I think
it blesses other people.
Is that what you wanted to hear?
JON CHUI: So it's just so
cool to hear stories like this
where-- look at
every other religion.
You know, like
every other religion
will tell you to be good to the
poor and do all these things.
But no other religion
gives you this joy
where it's like, in
his joy, this guy
sells everything and goes.
That would be my mine
thing for all of us
who call ourselves
followers of Jesus is,
are you doing this out of
this pure joy for Jesus?
So with that, we're
going to go to questions.
We have less than 10 minutes.
But for action
items, if you want
to talk to Kevin or any other
people-- Pat, raise your hand.
He's helping out the
Ethiopian mission thing.
In the back, Nick, can
you raise your hand?
Wave hive.
Nick is part of Go
Love as is Barb.
Barb, raise you hand.
They have been really
organizing a lot of the stuff.
If you go slash
love, it's basically
all the Christians who want
to actually act out in this.
There's action items there.
There's prayer groups.
We're going to try to do
events this year to volunteer.
And just go in
there to see more.
So Francis, did you decide which
questions you want to answer?
FRANCIS CHAN: Yeah,
in our seven minutes.
I'm going to just
hit one, otherwise
I'll just incompletely
answer everything.
Often I hear people appeal
to God's unbound love
and downplay his justness.
I think no one can experience
that love without repentance.
What would you
urge we Christians
do in midst of
increasingly disobedient
pro-choice pro-retaliation
culture we live in?
It's good.
The Bible says in 2nd
Timothy, chapter 3,
"He says understand this,
that in the last days
there will come
times of difficulty.
For people be lovers
of self, lovers
of money, proud,
arrogant, abusive,
disobedient to their parents,
ungrateful, unholy, heartless,
unappeasable, slanderous,
without self-control, brutal,
not loving good, treacherous,
reckless, swollen with conceit,
lovers of pleasure rather
than lovers of God,
having the appearance
of godliness
but denying its power.
Avoid such people."
And it continues a
few verses later.
"He says the time is
coming when people will not
endure sound teaching.
But having itching ears, they
will accumulate for themselves
teachers to suit
their own passions,
and will turn away from
listening to the truth
and wander off into myths.
As for you, always
be sober minded.
Endure suffering.
Do the work of an evangelist.
Fulfill your ministry."
He says in the
end times, there's
going to be a norm, a
norm in the world that's
always been there.
But the sad part is that norm is
going to leak into the church.
And that's where he's
saying avoid these people.
He's not saying avoid the world.
The same as in 1st
Corinthians 5, he says look,
I want you to avoid
sexually immoral people.
He goes I don't mean
the people in the world,
otherwise you'd have
to leave the world.
He goes, I am
saying specifically
anyone who calls
himself a brother
but lives this
immoral lifestyle.
He goes, I don't even
want you to eat with him.
So understand he's saying
here, he goes in the end times,
you're going to see people
that are self-centered,
people that are into pleasure
more than they're into God,
people who care less
about their parents,
people that are greedy.
And he's saying avoid them.
But he's not saying
avoid everyone
in the world like that.
He's saying in
the church, anyone
who calls himself a
Christian yet lives this way.
So our job is not
to judge the world.
That's God's job.
Our job, the Bible
says, we are supposed
to judge those in the church.
And this is where
we've got everything
backwards in the church where
we keep judging the world.
Oh, look at what they do here.
Look what they do here.
And then we leave all the
garbage that's in the church
alone.
And God is saying no,
it's the opposite.
I've called you to judge.
But I've called you to judge
those inside the church.
I'll take care of
the other part.
But those in your
church, he goes man,
you've got to get serious about
getting that out of the church.
And so that's my heart.
I hate this idea of
revenge or whatever else
when it comes into the church.
Thinking about using an example,
but I probably shouldn't.
So I'm going to
show self-control.
You want to do another one?
JON CHUI: Wow, great answer.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCIS CHAN: Was that good?
Want to hear another one?
JON CHUI: That was good.
Can you talk a little
bit about housing crisis
and social tensions
in the Bay Area SF,
given you work with
homeless in SF.
Any advice you can give
us on how we can radically
serve as God's people in tech?
People have been throwing stuff
at Google buses and things
like that.
FRANCIS CHAN: Yeah, I threw.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, we live in
a time when people
like to make broad
sweeping statements,
like all Chinese are smart.
You know, whatever.
We just like to say the homeless
or that group of people.
They're not all throwing
stuff at the bus.
And the thing I've
learned from meeting
with the homeless
or the people who
live in the SROs or the
addicts is that you really
can't put a label on people.
And I've met some of
the people that are so--
We adopted a girl out
of the Tenderloin.
Who yeah, she was a mess.
But she just needed a hand up.
She was there.
It seemed like she made some
decision to follow Jesus,
but living in a house with a
prostitute and drug addicts
everywhere, herself
getting involved
in some of those addictions.
I realized man, just to
have her in the house
and to have a dad that
loves her and just
have the social worker come
over and say, hey, your house,
they threatened to
shoot up your house.
And Dalal here who's only been
there for three weeks at a time
wants to know how long is
she allowed to live here.
And I said well,
I said honey, you
can live here as
long as you want.
I'm not afraid of that.
You see how I
treat my daughters.
I want you to be one of
them, if you'll have me.
You live here as long as you
want until you get married.
And even after that, if your
husband doesn't work real well,
you know like just-- you
know, whatever you need.
And for her eyes to
light up and say well,
you guys know if you adopt
her, there's no funding.
We don't care about funding.
We care about her.
And to see the
amazing young woman
she's become in a year and a
half, that's all she needed.
There's other people I've
worked with that you give them
the shirt off your
back and they just
keep taking advantage
of the system.
And they're always angry
no matter what you do.
You feed them and they complain
about the food you just
gave them.
And you just realize OK,
you're here by choice.
And we've given you every
chance in the world.
And you have so
much resource here.
And you are the problem and
you're not willing to face it.
And so there's like night
and day polar opposites.
And so what I would
encourage you to do
is get to know individuals.
I think that's been part of
our problem in the church.
We like to speak in generalities
about the issue in Mexico.
Whereas no one's actually
going and meeting Juan, right?
It's like I just want to
talk about this big thing
because I could
do that in a room.
But that's what changed me the
first time I went to Africa.
It wasn't these
starving Ugandans.
It was Dora.
It was Abisage.
It was Kenneth.
And they were my friends.
And I knew them.
And I had to do
something for Kenneth
because I really liked that kid.
I wanted to do
something for Abisage
because she cracks me up.
And that's where
everything changes.
And that's why in
our churches, we
don't say hey, these ex-cons.
But it's Robert.
It's Sean.
It's Birdo.
It's Raf.
It's this, it's that.
They are names to these people.
And they are our brothers,
and we love them.
And so you know, I know
we like to be in a room
and discuss that.
But I would say get to know
individuals and their names.
We gotta go.
JON CHUI: Cool.
I think we're out of time now.
So I think we're going -- are
you supposed to have a meeting
here, right now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
we've got a class.
JON CHUI: Oh, that's OK.
So we are going to need
to get kicked out of here.
If you can move the book
tables out into the foyer
or "foy-err", or whenever
you want to call it.
Thank you, Francis, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]